welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul and everywhere i go i
make the mando
django the fifth episode of the book of
boba fett is now here and throughout
this video we're going to be breaking
down the full episode talking about all
the easter eggs in it and also giving
our review of how the show is going so
far full spoilers ahead so if you don't
anything ruined then this video is gonna
be a little short like yoda
is that it is that the best we've got
this week right okay then well with that
all the way thanks for clicking this now
let's get into the book of boba fett now
last week saw us discovering how bubba
met fennick shanned and it tied directly
in with the fifth episode of the
mandalorian with this new ally barbara
and shan raided jabba's palace and
managed to take back slave 1. oh
i don't like that word yes word the
s-word sorry the prisoners with jobs
have armed themselves
okay that's better that's better
sorry in the prisoners with jobs one he
did a drive by unanito's riders and went
looking for his armor in the sarlacc pit
alas it was probably with kobanth at
this point and in present day bubba met
with the household heads they came to an
agreement that they wouldn't intervene
in the coming war between fett and the
pikes and we closed out with fenix
saying that we're gonna have to hire
some muscle now the episode is called
return of the mandalorian which spoiler
alert is because the big guy is back
directed by bryce dallas howard it's one
of the best in the season so far and we
pretty much get a mandalorian season 3
pilot as we follow him after the events
of season 2. we open in a meat packing
factory that looks like it was ripped
straight out of rocky which is where
we're reintroduced to the character he's
come to collect a bounty name cababas
but kaba no jabba in the meet slabber
now mando is still carrying the
armaments that he picked up in the
second season including the best score
spear that he got from the ahsoka
episode and the darksaber which mando
ended up taking at the end of season 2.
it's still up in the air whether he will
have to fight boko tam for this as not
only is it a badass weapon but it's also
a ceremonial one that decides who leads
mandalore he also has the tracking
divisor popped up in his show and he
comes across cabba gambling in the back
mando has actually run into clatunions
before and you might remember that they
raided a village during the first season
he knows it's him because he has a
hologram bounty chip which two showed up
when he was hunting fennec and because
the subtitles also say that it's him now
the clatunion isn't messing around and
he doesn't want to go in which leads to
mandel fighting his men in one of the
best action scenes so far the fight
isn't exactly one-sided and mano does
struggle at point strated showing how
unwieldy someone can be with a
lightsaber if they're not properly
trained he then cuts cabra in half which
looks like it hurts and takes the
platoonian's head with him mando really
shows how much he's changed as a
character because he says he has no
quarrel with those that he doesn't need
to fight and he even leaves credits
behind for them to take republic credits
are the new currency in the galaxy right
now and we did see in episode one that
they even had the rebellion crest on
them when they rolled out bob's helmet
cut to space for the first time in the
season and it's nice to actually be off
tatooine for once now this is a giant
orbiting ring that feels like it was
ripped right out of elysium which i've
put on screen right now in case you
haven't seen the film now we don't know
exactly what this location is but it
could be ringo vinder a space station
that has a similar design to the one
that we find ourselves on shout out
simone berman on twitter for pointing
out that the way the ship comes in is
very reminiscent of the star destroyers
in the empire strikes back and it helps
us to fully gauge the scale of how big
this thing is your boy slowly limps
along due to his injuries and he has
somewhat of an awkward elevator ride
with one of the locals maybe you're not
the one in spider-man 2 but that's
probably just me looking for connections
on the web that aren't there that's also
not even a good pun however what is good
is how they use this one shot take to
completely immerse you in the world we
go from the walk to the elevator to the
ball back to the elevator without
breaking or cutting and just completely
elevates this entire scene here manu
comes across his contact in ishi tib
which is an amphibious species that
comes from the planet to brin normally
they're green but i'm guessing that
living in space has changed this one's
complexion up it directs manu to call
zach alley and we further continue this
one take as we see exactly what he's
after i love how this scene is pretty
much a day in the life of the character
and we can watch as he trades bodies and
bounties on the black market in order to
gain access to information mano uses the
infrared vision scanner to locate hidden
sigils and this popped up in the first
season when he was tracking cara dune
here he comes across one that looks
slightly like a mythosaur which is a
symbol that the mandalorians use to mark
their territory it leads him to the
armorer who is back with one of the
soldiers that also appeared in the first
season this is paz vissler who you might
remember wielded a minigun on navarro we
find out some of the details that we
didn't know in the wake of that episode
including how almost all of the
mandalorians were wiped out leaving just
these three minor collapses and thank
god we don't go back to a bacter tank
because i i've had enough of them i'm
even sick of doing the pun at this point
now after presenting the dark cyber the
armor recounts the history of it and how
it's existed with the mandalorians for
ten thousand years she also talks about
how it must be won in combat which is
why bulkatan didn't take it at the end
of season two she very much gives us a
rundown of the darksaber including its
creator vissler who was both a jedi and
a mandalorian he was the ancestor of paz
and this somewhat makes him believe that
it belongs in his hands the weapon has
been contested for millennia and along
with moff gideon it's also fallen into
the hands of darth maul sabine wren also
gave it to bogotan and this somewhat
plays into the next part of the omri's
speech she talks about her royal lineage
later on and also discusses how the
character is somewhat a cautionary tale
she says that beau lost away and the
difference in the creeds were seen in
her and her crew removing their helmets
whereas the others wouldn't do this the
armor discusses how it's prophesied that
if it falls into the wrong hands without
being traded in combat that this can
lead to the destruction of mandalore
this is very much the case and we've
seen in bo gideon and maul how the
planet has been racked with war because
of those that seek it mandalore used to
be a thriving planet however in a civil
war and the galactic one led to it
becoming a harsh landscape much like
tatooine even though it's a harsh rock
at this point the people still fight for
it much in the same way that burba
fights for tatooine mano then joins the
covert and this is the way it looks like
things are gonna be but it doesn't last
long now we learned that gideon was also
sent off to be interrogated by the new
republic but the group don't really have
faith that he's gonna get the justice he
deserves
i'm saying it right now yeah shut the
hell up for a second moth gideon
mandalorian season three confirmed
that's an exclusive exclusive now they
rebuild the forge and melt the spear
into armor so that it can't be used as a
weapon on other mandalorians as the
armor melts it she brings up the moon of
concordia and also the great perch we
see this playing out with thai bombers
ransacking the planet in the night of a
thousand tears this happened in 19 bby
during the siege of mandalore it was
mentioned in episode 8 of the
mandalorian and gideon was very much at
the heart of it we see several machines
gunning down the survivors and these
include your typical probe droids as
well as the same model as k2so who you
might recognize from rogue one this kx
model of droid was primarily used for
security but here it's been sent out to
destroy and we watch as the fire burns
into the night there's a lot of imagery
here that also evokes terminator and
bryce dallas howard really knocks out
the park this entire episode amanda
wants the spear made into something for
grogu and though it's against the jedi
way to have attachments the mandalorians
are very much the opposite of this we
get an awesome smelting scene one of the
best smelting scenes i ever ever put to
film and all that's left is a small
pouch for the boy i love the way that
the bow is tied on this parcel and the
head and ears even somewhat resemble
grogu's head it's such a cool bit of
imagery and it's one of my favorite
parts of the episode that makes us
desperate to learn what's in the package
now because mando is so crap with the
darksaber he starts to train with the
armor who uses best score weapons which
as we know are capable of blocking it
the blade gets heavier the more that
mando wields it and this is because the
armor says he's fighting against it the
weight of this is clearly symbolic on a
number of levels and it could be the
case that mando is actually fighting not
only it but also what it truly means
whoever wields it is thought to be the
leader of mandalore and though beau has
often been thought of as being the true
heir i actually think it would work
better if mando's destiny was to take
back the planet and become its ruler him
fighting against this weight shows that
he doesn't want to go down this path but
it's only when he embraces it that it
becomes easier to wield his mind is
distracted likely over his need to be
with grogu and it's at this point that
paz contests the weapon removing their
jet packs they fight on a bridge that
looks looks very precarious should she
put a handrail up there and there are
flashes of when vader fought luke and
empire paz puts up one hell of a fight
and he manages to grab the blade from
mando but as he can't really wield it
either he struggles with the weight of
it which allows your boy to win now the
armor asks paz if he's ever removed his
helmet and she asks amanda the same
thing which as we know yet the guy has
done it a fair bit she says that he's no
longer a real mandalorian not a real fan
not a real star wars fan you and thus he
must travel to the living waters beneath
mandalore in order to somewhat baptize
himself rumor has it that they're
destroyed and thus mano heads out on
flight 1020 to tatooine this is the same
ship that we saw the pike army arriving
in and amongst the droids are some that
look like rx from galaxy tours kai sets
off the metal detectors and thus has to
remove his weapons in order to travel
this includes blast and the whistling
birds as well as the several detonators
a wire spool and the dark saber i love
how it takes so long that the q in the
background pretty much disappears and he
heads out into the galaxy i am kind of
wondering if this will pop up again and
that the pikes will manage to steal his
weapons when he travels out to see grogu
a bit of a fan theory there might not
happen but yeah they do spend a lot of
time on this scene now on the flight he
meets a green rhodium child that looks
somewhat like greedo and there's also a
dark grey astromech droid moe's isa
itself is filled with several droids and
as the ship lands we see the same
japanese-esque structures that also
appeared in the background of episode 3.
we also come across a bd droid which you
might recognize as being what kyle
kester's had as a slog companion in jedi
fall in order it's difficult to tell
whether this is the same one but it does
get called bd and yeah let's just say it
is mate because i want to see cal at
some point even though i think cameron
monahan might be a politician now or
something there's also r5 who appeared
in a new hope and on the top of him is a
hull where his busted motivator exploded
during that film bd is grabbed by a womp
rat and at this point pelimodo breaks
away from dating jawas to come out and
blast it amongst her are pit droids
which she too had in tow when she popped
up in episode 3. they're pretty useless
but mano shows up and saves the day he's
here to get a razor crest but instead
pally has the scraps of an n1
starfighter which you will probably
recognize as being the ships that naboo
used for their defenses in the phantom
menace i've always loved the design of
this ship and spent many hours flying in
it myself and yi old starfighter games
the ship is off grid because the empire
didn't register pre-war craft and this
is somewhat similar the race of crest
which was also able to fly under the
radar pelle says she'll modify it to
make it faster than a failure which were
the animals that popped up in the last
jedi during the during the best scene
best scene in a star wars movie ever now
the ship can also jump to hyperspace
without using docking rings which was an
issue that the jedi starfighters had we
spent a lot of time watching the ship
get fixed up and during the scene you
can catch markings along the bottom of
the cockpit i was hoping that these
would be the same as the ship that
anakin had but after checking them they
are different so this is another vessel
we also see a gunk droid being used as a
battery and bd showing holograms to
outline where the panel should be placed
the ship ends up looking very silvery
which of course mirrors the
mandalorian's best score armor and i'm
probably gonna waste most of the money i
make on this video buying the model for
this now it's at this point that the
jawas arrive peli talks to them in their
own language very nice and we also get
lip service paid to how the pikes are
pretty much running the planet at this
point the dawn is broken by the noise of
star wars version of a rooster and the
ship arrives completed even though it
still looks like it's falling apart now
the astromech droid port has been
removed and this is because as we
learned mano didn't like droids however
he did come to find an appreciation for
them after ig 11 saved his life and he
does seem a bit gutted he'll not have
any company on his flight he starts to
baby up which looks like it might even
have pod racer elements in it and we
actually passed the race track that
appeared in the phantom menace mano
touches upon several of the locations
that anakin passed through including
beggar's canyon and the ramp that had
its fence broken during the match it's a
great little call back to what's come
before amanda ends up flying up
alongside the rodian kid once more which
is a bit goofy but you know i like it i
like goofy stuff in star wars yeah sue
me now much in the same way that he had
to master the dark saber mano now has to
master flying a star fighter as opposed
to a gunship he says dank farrick a
curse word that has shot up in the star
wars universe at several points speeding
causes a lot of trouble though and thus
some x-wings come in to act like
policemen he's almost booked up but
carson teva recognizes his voice and you
might recognize him as being the x-wing
pilot that popped up in the second
season of the mandalorian manor denies
being the racer crest pilot that he's
encountered before and he blasts off
into space carson could chase after him
and write it up but he lets him go
because hey he's your boy nomano returns
back to the hangout where he's greeted
by fenix shand who's come looking for
him she says that she needs muscle and
it's on the house but mando has to pay a
visit to a little friend a little green
friend if you will likely your boy grogu
who we could be possibly seeing a bit
more grown up in the next entry and
maybe even luke skywalker who he was
last left with as we know from force
awakens kylo ended up wiping out luke's
jedi training academy but mano going to
visit him could mean that he ends up
taking him with him and this will save
the character and mean that he isn't
exterminated i think it would be great
if that happened and i can already tell
that this episode is going to go down
well with most people who haven't
enjoyed the show so far what do you mean
you still hate it i'm so sorry
there's nothing more i can do now i'm
hoping that all of the comments will be
more positive for this entry but i can
imagine that they will be saying the
best book of boba fett episode was the
one without him in that is pretty funny
to be fair but i this was a great entry
that i really enjoyed it was brilliant
seeing the continuation of mando's story
and the entry was also lit with cool
easter eggs and lots of call backs we
have the penultimate one next week and
the finale the one after i think it's
going to get really interesting as we
watch the war play out on tatooine which
i will of course be back for obviously
i'd love to hear your thoughts so make
sure you comment below and let me know
we are running a competition right now
and giving away three copies of an mc
boxer of your choice on the 30th of
january and all you have to do to be on
the chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
we pick the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one on screen right now so if
that's you then message me on twitter at
heavyspoilers if you want something else
to watch then make sure you check out
our breakdown of the perfect scene in
spider-man knowing home which will be
linked on screen right now we talk about
why this moment meant so much for andrew
garfield and also his version of peter
parker so definitely check it out right
after this if not then thanks for
sticking through the video i hope you
enjoy the rest of your day and you take
care yourself peace i'm out peace
[ __ ]
[Music]